ام
[موسيقى]
يروى ان ضائقه اقتصاديه ضربت قريه وضع ال
والى قدرا كبيرا في ساحتها وطلب من كل
مالك بقره وضع كوب من الحليب في القدر
ليله الاحد كبادره للتضامن في وقت الشده
في صباح الاثنين جمع الوالي اهل القريه
فيهم وفقيرهم ورفع الغطاء عن القدر فاذا
به ممتلئا بالماء الصافي كل صاحب البقره
قال في نفسه انك بمائه سيضيع بين اكواب
الحليب لكن الذي ضاع حقا هو المروءه
والاثار والتكافل وعندما تضيع هذه القيم
يصبح حليب البقر اغلى من دم البشر الى
العناوين
هاتوا مال السعوديه
فهي لا تملك غيره
ابن سلمان متجولا على ظهر الكعبه المشرفه
مسؤول اماراتي الصوفيه مذهب الخليج القادم
بوتفليقه ترشح خامسه بعين الحسود
شاعر من الحشد الشعبي يحن الى صدام
[موسيقى]
مرحبا المنشار وصل الى السعوديه مع عروض
الخطه في عام الترفيه العظيم ولم يبقى الا
الافراج عن الجثه او الرفاه او الرماد اذا
احرقت
هذا نائب امريكي يدعى تدليل تديره قطر
وتركيا وايران والجيش الاحمد الايرلندي و
نمور التاميل وتحالف الجن الازرق يقول
عادل الجبير انت كاذب وتعلم مكانه خاصه
بعد ما قد تعتبره اراده مع التحفظ على
عباره اراده كلمه مؤثره ليس وليد ما تاثر
عندما سمعا قرارا دوليا بان الجريمه محليه
مائه بالمائه بدون وافده ال اتهمت مقرره
الامم المتحده الخاصه بالتحقيق في قتل
خصخصه انيس كلامار المسؤولين السعوديين
باعاقه جهود المحققين الاتراك واضافت ان
الجريمه كانت متعمده لتخطيط وتنفيذ سعودي
على الامريكيين ان يعلموا ان نشر الخطط
عندنا ممنوع وان وزاره البيئه السعوديه
اقرت غرامات ماليه تنتصر الى نصف مليون
ريال بحق مع دبي القطاع الم تلاحظ ان
الخطه الوديعه في القنصليه السعوديه
باسطنبول لم يؤدها احد
نيويورك تايمز ماذا تريد مني حتى تنقل من
ارشيف السي اي اي ان الامير محمد ابلغ
الاعلامي تركي الدخيل في سبتمبر ايلول
الفين وسبعه انه يخبئ هديه صغيره
سيتسلمها حال عودته الى السعوديه والهديه
هي رصاصه ساخنه بدناش مشاهير
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه افادت
الخميس بان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان قال خلال محادثاته مع احد
المقربين منه وهو تركي الدخيل عام الفين
وسبعه عشر انه سيذهب الى حد استخدام رصاصه
ضد الصحفي جمال خاشقجي اذا لم يعد الى
السعوديه بكامله
رصاصه الامير براءه اختراع تم تسجيلها على
الاقل قبل عشرين عاما عندما وضعها الامير
الفتى انذاك على مكتب قاض كبير في الرياض
لاقناعه بالحسنى بحسب تقرير لبي بي سي كان
هناك نزاع قانوني حول صفقه ارض ذهب محمد
بن سلمان الى مكتب القاضي الاعلى في
الرياض ووضع رصاصه على المكتب قال له اما
ان تفعل ما نريد او تحصل على هذه وزير
الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه عادل الجبير يرفض
التعليق على رصاصه نيويورك تايمز فيما
اكتشف اعلامه مصدر الفتنه تركيا وقطع
الجبير كان محاوله الربط بين ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان وقضيه خاصه جيل
اسلحه هذا وتواصل السلطات القطريه والتركي
هجماتها على السعوديه والنظام ها القطاع
في محاوله على ما يبدو للاستمرار في اعطاء
جريمه قتل الصحفي السعودي جمال خاشقجي بعد
ما هي الابعاد الاخرى ال محتمله للجريمه
بعدما لي سعود القحطاني مثلا المنتج
امريكا من استمراره ضمنيا في منصبه ومن
تجوله في ابو ظبي سعود بيع سياره لجمال
ومش مسدد
البعد الطائفي
لكن المقتول والقتل من مذهب واحد
بعد عاطفي ربما هناك من اراد تعطيل زواج
جمال من خديجه لغايه في نفسه ماهر المطرب
الذي يقول الجبير انه لا يعلم مكانه ولا
حتى مصيره وله وزير خارجيه حضرتك او
بالاحرى وزير الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه
اين ابراهيم العساف بالمناسبه وزير
الخارجيه الجديد هلا بتعرف من جديد الى
معهد الريد للترويض في الرياض
اخيرا خرجت السعوديه عن صمتها واعربت عن
اسفها الاقتراح الذي تقدمت به المفوضيه
الاوروبيه لادراج الرياض في قائمتها
السوداء للدول المتعاونه في مكافحه تبييض
الاموال وتمويل الارهاب
ونقل بيان رسمي عن وزير الماليه محمد
الجدعان قوله ان التزامنا بمكافحه غسل
الاموال وتمويل
الارهاب اولويه استراتيجيه هذا هو الموقف
الصلب الذي عودتنا عليه حكومه المملكه
وكما يقول القائد عادل الجبير لا احد يملى
علينا ماذا يجب ان نفعل
الاترام هو
مايك
ايفانكا وجون وجوزيف وبولتون والشباب
الامر سيطبق بالنسبه الى السعوديه واخرين
نحن نحن السعوديه انه لا يملكون شيئا اخر
غير المال ونحن نوفر لهم الحمايه مع
مساعده كبيره نحن المقدمه للسعوديه
المساعده والعكس هو الذي يجب ان يحصل
بالنسبه به الله الله ما علينا لا يلزمني
[موسيقى]
لم يعد هناك اي سبب لاستمرار الخصومه بين
النظامين السعودي والسوري فقد وضعهما
التقرير السنوي لمنظمه فريدوم هاوس
الامريكيه على مقعدين متجاورين في اخر دول
العالم
[موسيقى]
حتى يبقى مؤشر خصومات الرياض العربيه
والاسلاميه فصاعدا مشكله جديده مع المغرب
الذي انسحب من تحالف حرب اليمن واستدعي
سفيره في الرياض للتشاور اليمن وقطر
والصحراء الغربيه اسباب يبدو انها اشعلت
خلافا بين المملكتين المغربيه والسعوديه
المغرب اعلن انسحابه من التحالف الذي
تقوده السعوديه اليمن واستدعي سفيره لدى
الرياض للتشاور نامل ان تكون سحب صيف
مستحب سيف تست له كتائب الشتائم
الالكترونيه التي لا تقيم حرمه لا لرجل
ولا لحرمه عتبوا الحكومه المغربيه كبير
على السعوديه التقرير الذي بثته قناه
العربيه السعوديه وهو الذي اثار حفيظه
المغرب والذي يتعامل مع ملف الصحراء
الغربيه الحساس والشائكه لدى المغربي اه
تبني وجهه نظر جبهه البوليساريو نحن ننظر
لقناه العربيه باعتبارها وسيله اعلاميه
حره لديها يعني مساحه تتحدث بما تريد كما
ان هناك مئات من التوصيات المناسبه
العالميه
السعوديه رسميه كاعلامي لا استطيع الا ان
نتضامن مع قناه العربيه وان اعتبر انه لا
يمكن تحميلها مسؤوليه تدهور علاقات الدول
مع السعوديه بسبب ما تبثه من برامج تماما
مثلما نطالب حلف القمار بفصل موقفه من
الجزيره عن علاقاته مع قطر والعكس صحيح
كذلك سن تضامن مع العربيه اذا طالب المغرب
باقفالها فهم يضعونها الان في خانه واحده
مع حزب الله الدعايه التي قامت بها قناه
العربيه لكيان يسمى البوليزاريو اعلن
المغرب منذ شهور عن قطع العلاقات مع ايران
لماذا لان دائره وحزب الله تدعم هذا
الكيان الا تعتقد بان قناه العربيه
المدعومه من طرفه جهه ما انها تقف في نفس
الصف اليوم المغرب مع حزب الله وايران
السياسيون ياكلون الحصرم
والاعلاميون يدرسون الاعلامي القطري ماجد
الخليفي يسال الاعلاميه السعودي احمد
الفهد لماذا تتحدث الان عن علاقه قطر
بايران ولم تفعل ذلك قبل عامين حبيبي انت
دائما تكون ضيف دائم في في استوديوهات عن
وات الدوري والكاس لم تتكلم مره عن عن عن
علاقتها قطر الرياضيه مع ايران الان في
هذه الازمه ظهرت هذه الاسلحه بدوره اسال
الاعلام القطري هل كان ينتقد السعوديه قبل
الازمه وهل رات الجزيره عيبا واحدا في
السعوديه قبل الازمه نحن نتمنى ان تعود
العلاقات الاخويه بين الدول الخليجيه افضل
من مكانه لكن تضمن حريه اعلامكم فهذه ضمن
مواصفات العالم الجديد ياللي اثنين حالكم
على مقعد في تلك
[موسيقى]
في الدوحه وقعت قطر وفرنسا ممثلتين بوزيري
الخارجيه محمد بن عبد الرحمان الثاني
قضائي بندر يوم اتفاقيه للحوار
الاستراتيجي بين البلدين تشمل الملفات
المشتعله وال عالقه في المنطقه تزامنا
وقعت المملكه العربيه السعوديه اتفاقيه
تعاون مع الممثل محمد هنيدي وعدد من
الفنانين المصريين الاخرين وقد مثل
المملكه ملك الترفيع
[تصفيق]
وقال رئيس مجلس اداره الهيئه العامه
للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ مذكره تفاهم لتدعيم
القطاع الطبي بالمملكه هلا تركي الشيخ اه
بيمشي بالشارع على قدمين وحضرتك ممكن
تتعامل مع الناس هنا في الشارع يعني
كثير والله كثير ما حدا مات من الجوع
حياتها انا من تسعه وثمانين ويمشي وروح
الشارع او شعبيه
تركي سينتج مسلسلات بوغرا فيه عالميه لا
تروي سير عظماء التاريخ الاسلامي والعربي
ولا ملوك السعوديه و علمائها وادبائها نعم
نعم يا حبيب نعم فات الميعاد والحبيب
للهجري مايل ورقم السعد عشرين ثلاثين
اتكلم مع شركات امريكا وبريطانيا كلثوم
عبد الحليم ونتيجه مسلسلات عالميه في
العالم بس تبدي حصريا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بما اننا منتجين منديل معمر
القذافي الذي دعمت قطر والسعوديه الاطاحه
به على الاقل انتج فيلم الرساله وعمر
المختار
لكن من قال ان نشاطات هيئه الترفيه لا
تعبر عن الدين الحنيف يسال مطر من عيار لا
تضربني لا تضرب كسرت الخيزرانه
اعتقد ان هذا العنوان الذي عنوان والترفيه
لكن مضامين مختلفه جدا تحمل الرساله
الوطنيه الله وحتى شرعيه تعبر عن ديننا
وعن ثقافتنا
[تصفيق]
على خشبه اخرى تتحول هيئه الترفيه الى
هيئه التسويه بهيئه التنبيه وفي الهيئه
هيئه
الترفيهيه ما كان عندهم انت بريء حتى تثبت
ادانته كان عندهم
الجماعه ينتقدون علمائهم فلماذا لا
ينتقدون جماعه التبليغ المشهوره بالابتعاد
عن السياسه والجدل لم يتركوها فاتهموها
بالارهاب والاتهام وجاء في مقابله اجرتها
صحيفه عقاب مع في احمد في مستشار وزير
الشؤون الاسلاميه
والخلفيات الاستراتيجيه مفتي السعوديه
كانوا يشيدون بجماعه التبليغ فالمطلوب
توضيح الموقف من تاريخ مؤسسه الافتاء
السعودي هذا المندوب الدائم للامارات في
الان سكو مثلا
فالمطلوب عنده خليج وفي جاءت الحركه
الوهابيه تاريخيا اه
يعني ال ال القضاء على بعض مظاهر اه مثلا
التبرك وعمليه الاطرحه وما شابه ذلك قد
تكون الصوفيه هي الاقرب اه
اقرب المذاهب الى الروحاني بهذه الطريقه
شهد صاحب الكعبه المشرفه حاله منع تجول
مؤقته المعتمرين والمصلين افساحا في
المجال لجوله ولي العهد على اعمال توسعه
الحرم الشريف ترافقه كتيبه امنيه الجوله
توجت بحدث وصف بالغريب حيث اعتلى بن سلمان
ظهر الكعبه مسعود فهو امر غريب حتى ان
الاعصار عندما دخل مكه لم يتحدث عن الكامل
بعد ثلاثين عاما من الاعتزال اخيرا اقنعت
السعوديه فنانه الاستعراض المبدعه شيريهان
بالعوده الى خشبه المسرح حيث ستقدم
لعائلات المملكه عروضا مميزه
[موسيقى]
انجلينا جولي نجمه هوليود زارت مخيمات
اللاجئين روهينغا في بنغلاديش ودعت العالم
الى الاهتمام بهم ايمانا منه بواجب
حمايتهم اطلق الامير محمد بن سلمان اكبر
صندوق عالمي
لحمايه النمور العربيه انا ولي العهد قد
يطلق اليوم محميه شرع ان الطبيعيه في
محافظه العلا كما تشمل هذه المبادره انشاء
اكبر صندوق عالمي من نوعه لحمايه النمر
العربي تقريبا خمسه وعشرين مليون دولار
يعني لهذا المشروع اه تقريبا اعاده توطين
اطلاق الاهتمام في حمايته لانها لا يوجد
لمائتي نمر فقط في المملكه من الن من
العربي الذي مهدد بالانقراض على مستوى
العالم اطلاق عشرات الغزلان والطيور يبعث
على الامل بان يصل التسامح الاميري الى
معتقلات العلماء والمثقفين والنساء العام
وهو يطلق تلك الوعول اطلق تقريبا عشره عشر
من طيور النعام احمر الرقبه وكذلك عشرين
من الغزلان اذا اليوم نحن ولله الحمد
نعيشه من فرحات الوطن
[موسيقى]
تركي الدخيل صار سفيرا للسعوديه في
الامارات لكن ادائه الدبلوماسي منذ اللحظه
الاولى لا يعد بانه سيكون افضل من ادائه
الاعلامي فهو نشر صوره وعلق عليها
شرفني سمو الشيخ عبد الله بن زايد وزير
الخارجيه بدوله الامارات بان اتى حاليا
موعدا وسط التزاماته الله اكبر يا شيخ
استاذ تركي انت مش دخيل على الامارات انت
تمثل السعوديه العظمى وجلاله ملك ها تكشف
الوثائق ان الدخيل يحصل على مبالغ كبيره
من حكام الامارات
هذه الوثيقه مثلا تشير الى حصول الدخيل
على مبلغ وقدرها ستمائه وثلاثه وثلاثون
الف دولار امريكي من وزير الخارجيه
الاماراتي الحالي عبد الله بن زايد تم
تحويل هذا المبلغ الى حساب الدخيل في
الثالثه عشر من تموز يوليو عام الفين
واربعه عشر بدا هواتفنا هذا الاسبوع مقدم
برنامج الرياضيه على قناه دبي يسقط سنه
على الهواء اثناء انفعالها على رئيس اتحاد
كره القدم الاماراتي الذي يرفض الاعتراف
بفشل الامارات في بطوله اسيا انا ما قد
يمكن عياله بعد متفقين
ذلك يعني كل من التفضيل على الحسره اللي
احنا فيها اجماع
شو يعني اي موضوع معرض ان يسقط منه شيء
على الهواء المهم ان لا تسقط منا اخلاق
المهنه هذا النظام اللي وضع مستقبل القطر
وثروات قطر وشعب القطر في مهب الريح
اسمه باخلاق وافعال قرار جدا تحدث عنها
تعرض المعلق الرياضي العماني خليل البلوشي
لهجوم اعلامي اماراتي حاد بسبب تكراره في
مقطع فيديو تعليقا كان استخدمه في مباراه
قطر الامارات الشهيره حيث يقول بالشمع
الاحمر الهيدوس داس عليهم دوس ووصل الامر
الى مطالبات يتبرء العمانيين من البلوشي
طويل عريض وداخل في لا يمثلنا ولا يمثل ثم
ما قال لا يمثلنا فلان وعلان اللي يعني ما
قالوا ما يمثل نا يعني عفوا محمد بن زايد
لما ايضا اه يعني في في خليه تجسس الكبرى
يعني ما قداس عليهم دوس في خليه التجسس
معنا عنها كان في التلفزيون العماني و
باقرار رسم عماني ويقول لك ان في محاوله
الوصول الى من النظام العماني والوصول الى
الاقتصاد العماني ما حتى العقل نتبرا من
فلان ليس ل خليل البلوشي الحقب هذا
التعليق والله اعلم عليه ان يحترم ادبيات
الملعب ففي ذلك الملعب مسموح فقط رمي الن
عال في وجوه اللاعبين
راع كتدرائيه الانبه انطونيوس في ابو ظبي
يشيد بتغيير الشيخ محمد بن زايد اسم
المسجد بعد ان دورته كنيسه قدم بن زايد
ارضها وامر الشيخ اه صاحب السمو الشيخ
محمد بن زايد اه رعاه الله اه ولي عهد
ابوظبي نائب القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
تغيب امره تغير اسم هذا المسجد من مسجد
محمد بن زايد الى مسجد مريم ام عيسى عليه
السلام السؤال هو لماذا لم يبقى اسم
المسجد كما هو مسجد محمد بن زايد والكنيسه
تسمى ايضا كنيسه محمد بن زايد طالما انه
قدم ارضها وللتعبير عن روح التسامح اذا لم
يكن هناك مانع ديني طبعا
[موسيقى]
عثر علماء في جنوب الارجنتين على هيكل
عظمي لديناصور
باسواق حاده وطويله على عموده الفقري وقد
تم عرض مجسم تشبه لديناصور المنقرض الرئيس
عبد العزيز بوتفليقه وافق اخيرا على
الترشح لولايه رئاسيه خامسه الرئيس عبد
العزيز بوتفليقه يعلن ترشحه رسميا لرئاسه
الثامن عشر ابريل القدم بعض المعارضين
يفتحون عند كل استحقاق الملف الصحي للرئيس
مع انه من اختصاص الاطباء
السيده لفخامه الرئيس هذا الاختصاص
من اختصاص سياسيه الرئيس هو دائما عند حسن
ظن الشعب فيه لكن يبقى على الشعب ان يثبت
انه في مستوى تطلعات الرئيس بوش حمله جهه
والشعب يكون شاء الله في مستوى تطلعات
الرئيس توفيق اولا يتطلع الى منافسه
بوتفليقه باصوات النساء ف برنامجه
الانتخابي من ماده واحده اعدام الرجل الذي
يطلق زوجته اللي عنده
هذا
[موسيقى]
ال متفرقات وزير الخارجيه المصري يريد
مواقف ملموسه من قطر لتغيير الموقف منها
اه اذا كنت بتسال الموقف المصري في الموقف
المصري واضح انه لن يكون هناك استعاده
طبيعي في العلاقات الا عندما يكون هناك
تغير ملموس في السياسات القطريه يعني موقف
الموت هكذا يلمس
في العاده عندما يقع الانسان في ازمه يلجا
الى الدين الرئيس السوداني عمر البشير
مثال على هذه الحاله اكدها رئيس الجمهوريه
المشير عمر البشير ان تطبيق الخاطئه
لقانون النظام العام خلق من وسط الشباب
واضاف انها تطبيق القانون مخالف للشريعه
بنسبه مائه وثمانين بالمائه هناك امكانيه
كبيره للمصالحه بين المتعارضين في كراكاس
بعد حلقه على قناه سعودي اربعه وعشرين
ناقشت ازمه فنزويلا غيرت اسمي الرئيس
ورئيس البرلمان نفوت الامور ببعضها
عمل ها الشي ولان
ويرتمي في احدى الدول ارهابيه هذا
يعني الان واحد
يريد الشعب الجديد
رئيس البرلمان اخوان الجويده الذي نصب
نفسه رئيسا جاهز لاستدعاء تدخل عسكري
امريكي للاطاحه بالرئيس نيكولاس مادورو
المثل يقول مات من مات تدخل عسكريون
امريكي ان اقتضت الضروره هو ما هدد به
مجددا اخوان جيده للاطاحه بندور وانهاء
الازمه الانسانيه شاعر من الحشد الشعبي
كفر بالطبقه الحاكمه وترحم على صدام حسين
فاكمل قصيدته في السجن
اخيرا وئام وهاب
السليمه بالمفرق فوصف لبنان بالجمله بانهم
البنت السوق لبنان مثل مثل مثل
التعبير مثل بنت السوق يعني من مكان
بياخذوا وبيظهر معها يعني اه هذا لبنان
[موسيقى]
ختاما ما يعرف اهل حمص يدرك دم اتهم
وذكائهم بخلاف الطرائف الشائعه حولهم
والطريف ان ذكاء الحماس هو السبب في سمعه
السياسه هذه وتعود القصه الى زمن الاجتياح
المغولي لبلاد الشام فكانت نشات اهل حمص
من بطش تيمور لنك بتصنعهم الغباء والجنود
في الشوارع والساحات و ب اشاعه ان مياه
نهر العاصي الذي يروي مدينتهم تسبب هذه
الافه فابتعدت جيوش المغول عنها حتى لا
تذهب عقولهم وحفظ الله حمص بنسائها
ورجالها
واطفالها قد يكون احيانا التظاهر بالغباء
قمه في الذكاء وهناك من يعتقد ان اكثر من
حاكم معاصر يعتمدون هذه الحيله ل تمرير
مخططاتهم
وهناك من يعتقد العكس بانهم اغبياء لكنكم
لا تصدقوا الى اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]